how are you students from
chile near here with you
well my name is jayson silva I am
the presenter of mind games who
knows mind games here
but how wonderful
well it really is an honor an honor to
be here with you I don't know if you
know but  i'm also latino i'm
from venezuela so thank you
so it's an extra special honor to
be here sharing with you in
spanish since most of the time
my talks are in english
well as i tell you my name is jayson
silva and being the host of
mind games you already know that I have
a passion for human creativity
I have a passion for science I have
a passion for imagination and this
has become for me a passion
for technology in innovation
and the reason for this is that the  technology
is an expression of human creativity
in physical form technology is
literally human imagination in
physical form technology is how we
express our  Our greatest creativity in the
world and technology is how
we overcome all our
limitations technology is how we evolve and
how we reach new levels
of creativity and imagination capacity
and it has always been that way that is what
many don't realize many think
that  only today that technology
has become something so disruptive
but technology has always
transformed the world technology
has always been used by
human beings to overcome their limitations
if you go back in history and
go 100,000 years ago to Africa when  the
first human beings began to
explore the earth and the first
human beings picked up a stick on the ground
and used it to reach a fruit
that was left on a tree that was very
tall we have used our
instruments even the most
basic instruments to overcome our
limitations to transcend our
limits
has always been like that as the
philosopher m  arshall mcluhan we
we build the tools and
the tools build
us there is a circular relationship between
the human being and his tools
now today we live in a time of
accelerated change we live in a time where
this technological evolution is
reaching levels that we cannot almost  nor
understand innovation is accelerating
the changes are exponential
but the reason is because it is different
today from the eras of the past since as
I told you technology has always
transformed humanity since we
domesticated the fire or we created
airplanes or  cell phones the
internet electricity technology
has always transformed humanity
but because today we use these
expressions of exponential change of
exponential acceleration
that is the most important word in my
talk today to understand why the
world is changing because we are
evolving
from  this way you should understand
the  The concept of exponential change since
the human being and the brain of the
human being thinks of change in a linear way
because we come from a linear and
local world and today we live in a global and exponential world,
so what is the difference between
linear change and change  exponential
the futurologist records while among the
most famous in the world in his abilities
to predict the future uses a
wonderful example the example of the 30 steps
if you take 30 linear steps one two
three four five or six thirty steps
then you reach 30 that is logical  30
linear steps you get to 30 but 30
exponential steps ok the same number
of steps but exponentials you get to
a trillion
billion
try to conceive of those 30
linear steps of you get to 30 30
exponential steps that reach a billion
or standing
that  that's the reason
that's the reason understand this that the
smartphone the iphone or the
android that you carry in your
pocket ok it
's a million times more  It's cheap a
million times smaller and a thousand times
more powerful than a supercomputer
that 40 years ago occupied the size of this
building cost 60 million dollars
and needed your special permission to
use it
understand this 60 million dollars and
the size of this building  in the
supercomputer 40 years ago and that
computer thanks to this
exponential progress has been reduced to the telephone
that you carry in your pocket a
supercomputer that today fits in
your pockets
understand that a million times
cheaper a million times smaller and
a thousand times more powerful, what that
means is that each of you has the tools to
transform the world and society
in your
pockets.
Think about the potential to
transform the world that each
of you has in your pockets
and this progress  exponential is
not going to slow down this
exponential progress continues
therefore that in the next 25 years
this telephone  Smartphone is going to reduce
somewhat the size of a cell that is going to go
inside our brains, increasing
our intelligence and giving us
capacities to innovate and overcome.
Now I am a passion of mine and I
love making videos on social networks
to share the
implications of  these
exponential technologies so I would like to
show you some videos while the
talk continued so yes please
can you show back there the first
video being human is being trans human
in sex
[Music]
on air
software engineer
uruguay on web
you are  you
when
and
well for that thank you friends thank you
obviously the videos are in English
but I have them subtitled so that
way you can also practice
video jaime in cities
well as I have been talking to you the
technologies in innovation advances in
this exponential way and I think that
you already begin to understand the
speed of the change that is coming and
therefore the  potential for transformation
that is coming for you is the potential
which you can apply in your
careers in what motivates you every day
to impact the world now I have had
the opportunity to travel around the
world giving these talks and speaking
with government corporate audiences
at times  students and what
people often tell me is
how shocking the way
technology is changing is true it's
hard to believe but I believe it because
I've lived it each one of you
has surely seen how five
years ago the computer cost such  price
had a certain capacity and today it
is twice as powerful and worth half
so with how incredible these projections are,
people still understand it
because they have seen it, however what
people tell me sometimes is and what happens with it
world of biology and the world of
concrete and cement in which we live
because obviously what is advancing
exponentially is computer science.
digital ca but the biological world and the
concrete world in which we live
is not the same but it turns out that the
biological world and the concrete and
cement world are also becoming
computer technologies
software is here in the world
software is eating  the world
understand this let's start with
biology biology or what is
emerging right now the technology of bio
technology synthetic biology
genetics that basically allows the
human being to become a
biology software programmer biology
is obviously made of a genetic language
we are made of a language
just like the digital language we have
a biological language and our
ability to program is the
biological language is also advancing
exponentially so there is going to be
a transformation a new era
of medicine
of synthetic genetics of synthetic biology
where the ability of the
human being to manipulate to program and to
improve the s  software of our biology is
going to transform what it means to be a
human being
the new trillion ary industries are going
to be the industries of biological informatics
what they call sincere what a law
and in having ex
the speed at which we are
progressing ok in understanding in  sequencing
in psycho turn on and gnome the genome is
advancing three times faster than the
exponential numbers that I told you before
that means that in 20 years we are
going to be able to cure all
diseases with new
biological software but that the new industries
of the  Medicine is going to give us capabilities
of more intelligence of more innovation
that is going to change the definition of the human being it
is going to be the human being 2.0
and as I tell you this is also
advancing exponentially even
faster than the exponential
now as the philosopher who ben
helli said
Just imagine how poor the human race would be
if we hadn't invented the
technology of the musical instrument at
time for beethoven and mozart to
use that technology to create the
magical music that they have created
so I took that technology and applied
it today that new geniuses like you
are going to create in the world equipped
with these new
exponential technologies what are the going to be  works
of art made works of art made
with synthetic genetic technology
alternated there without being clouded and a
definition to see means to be human
and this is advancing exponentially, as I say
,
also understand this nanotechnology
is a technology that allows us to
program atoms  of the physical world its
program building workshop of the physical
world that means that the physical world
becomes programmable software
also
imagine a building that builds itself
what we are talking about with
nanotechnologies the sampling buildings
computers that build themselves
software that creates its own hardware
and well the artificial intelligence that
works  It is today inside your
phones and soon it will work
inside your brains in combination with
biological intelligence are the three
exponential technologies and
nanotechnology in reflection intelligence
and in
generix nanotechnology in europe which are
the three exponential technologies that are
going to create a world  where the only
limit is the imagination of the
human being so you have to know that
everything is going to be possible so don't
limit yourself and this next video explores
those three technological revolutions
please second video youtube
these watchguard qms next this is what
there is
and
there isn't
[Music]
at the moment
and
so what was the eyes
emotions emotions
[Applause]
now obviously I'm painting a
picture of what's coming but what's coming can
already be seen today everyone has them
all of you  they have access to the internet,
for example, and today we associate the internet
with computers and with
mobile phones, smartphones p  but it
turns out that there is a revolution coming that
is just beginning and it is called the
internet of things
in the internet of things is what
happens when the internet goes beyond
the screens of your phones
beyond the screens of your computer and
it gets into regular objects that are
around us all the time
because because sensors are
advancing exponentially they get
smaller more powerful and cheaper
so we put power into them by putting
sensors on all objects and
turning all objects into
smart objects all  the objects
connected to a network the network of internet things
headquarters and everything will have
intelligence in the same way that the
human being electrified the world uy
electro fire the world with
electricity now we are making the
whole world intelligent
aliens in  two three day jacks that is going to
allow us to create an enchanted
world a magical world a world that knows what we
want before we  others
know it a world that makes us
intelligent recommendations a world
with contextual computing that
understands us and helps us at all times
what this world is going to be
like how we can participate in this world
what kind of career we can imagine
to do as creators of this world
smart
this oriental revolution of jeans
tennis is something a bit hard to
imagine so another video to
help you understand the concept third
video please
ok
[Music]
x
we will also see a man
[Music]
in the city
on smartphones this dance number
[Music]
although whoever's head exploded
some brain explorer vers
ok well look obviously I'm a presenter
of mind games and in a way
I'm making it a mind game
I love you  inspire and I want to help
you imagine what is possible based on
emerging
technologies emerging technologies that we are already seeing today
beginning of this
transformation however this is
obviously super cool but we have to
use these technologies to impact
the world in a positive way if I
ask each one of you would you
like to end up having a career
that gives you passion that gives you purpose and
that makes  the world a little better
raise your hands you would like that
when your parents with your friends with your
teachers ask you what are you going to do
what are you going to study this event is called
evolution to the question is do you want
an ordinary job that gives you
some money to survive or you want
a passion a purpose where you use
tools to positively impact the world
a reason to get out
of bed every day to feel
worthwhile to feel like you are
contributing true
yes or no
therefore we create  a
digital campaign called let's
redefine the billionaire because because
today all millennials want
to be like mark zuckerberg and create a
company in his room with a little bit of
fellow code and become the
next billionaires of zurich
standard bearer and yet we
think that in the era of
exponential technologies
the term billionaire should be redefined
a billionaire today  you are not a
person with a billion dollars that is
incidental a billionaire today you are
a person who positively
affects a billion people that makes you a
billionaire in the age of exponential technology
therefore my invitation to everyone
It is up to you to conceive how I can
each of you participate impact
redefine what the world is how you
contribute to the world how you
positively impact the world and how I can
become a billionaire by
positively touching a billion people
that is  the new definition and that is
what I wish for you this next
video explains the concept of us
as the captains of the ship  from the
land
of peace villiers and weaken one link
guy so please pay attention to
this next video
on may 6
at sea
[Music]
the people
[Music] I
remember what happened
[Music]
richard sean a  the default tribe
my h
how
is the challenge for you there is the invitation
for each of you
you should not feel nervous about
the radical technological changes in the
world you should never feel very
excited in life and never
in history  of mankind there has been
so much potential to affect the world in
a positive way never in the history
of mankind have we been so
connected to each other never in the history of
mankind when someone asks
you what are you going to study what do you want to
do what is it  your passion how are you going
to make a living I want you to
invite you to respond you know
that I want to do something that
positively affects a billion people I
do  piro I want to get out of bed
every day with the desire to be an
entrepreneur to evolve
to transform to innovate to imagine
how I can make this world better
accept the challenge
please
I call these videos pills of
amazement
and the reason is because this emotion  of
wonder for me is an addiction but a
very positive addiction because it inspires
me every day to want to awaken
people's consciousness to want to awaken the
sense of wonder to want to awaken
curiosity because that nourishes us that
pushes us to go further
recently there have been studies in  the
universities of stanford and berkeley
on the positive cognitive effects
of wonder because it turns out that
wonder is not only divine but
also makes us more creative, it
increases empathy, it increases compassion and
makes us feel very well
beyond the initial experience
so what is wonder in the shadow
is an experience where our
perception is stretched from  way so
intense by sepsi behind leds that our
perception pushed to levels
beyond the models we carry about what
is possible and what exists
essentially slaps us in the
face and wakes us up to the miraculous in
front of us the
miraculous possibilities  the technologies that
reflect our ability to innovate
in an inconceivable way
some of you are trying to imagine
is how something like a
facetime call or a
video conference call works from a
wireless machine without being plugged in it can open
an interdimensional portal ok that
collapses the  distance and that opens a
window for us to another person
across town or across the world and
that it works somehow we have
achieved that as just a small example
of the world we live in
if you are not amazed by something as
basic as  the smartphone in
your pockets are asleep so I
invite you to wake up and also if you have
enjoyed  After routing the videos, I invite you to
follow me on the networks where you can see
all these videos.
[Music] it
was hurtful x3 win tín specter to
choose in now
[Music]
and it's true
efe
[Music]
light
in the public space a lot of details
and that he
[Music]
a million thanks I love you
thank you very much for the opportunity
and i wish you all the best thanks
a big round of applause for jason